les chéris je vais appuyer là-dessus
puisque je me suivait un petit cadeau ce
soit chez toutes ces personnalités qui
vont souhaiter bon anniversaire
mais moi je voulais une personne c'est
un groupe me souhaite bon anniversaire à
si ça c'était mon rêve absolu sans
avenir le dos et je vais m'appuyer
là-dessus et j'espère qu'on est en route
vers une réconciliation puisque ce soir
le groupe tf1 ne m'a souhaité bon
anniversaire à leur façon regardez
[Applaudissements]
c'est en direct sur tf1 on vient de
poster bonne anniversaire baba on t'aime
merci déchets ça s'est passé dans le
quartier vous allez voir pas
d'anniversaire baba au thème merci
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
oh la grosse bête selon la cour de cfa
merci tu es sa merci je vous aime les
chéris merci d'avoir pensé à moi
on laissera sa tant que personne
n'arrête voilà donc si vous passez et
ben vous verrez bon anniversaire baba
merci et merci de mai mais merci loïc
merci et nous on trouve théâtre le 3
octobre on est très heureux très bon
horoscope au théâtre et abusives avec le
monde merci val vit bien il a fait
l'erreur était là merci à vous deux mois
on aura la garde qui sera avec
l'incendié
il y aura d'autres surprises des cherry
je continue à appuyer s'il voulait pas
la télé